ciao ragazzi ecco il nuovissimo video
che parla come salutano le persone prima
dirvi a cancellare il telefono mi è
venuta questa idea perché a quell'ora in
giro ho sentito una ragazza chiusissima
che adesso giunta del compenso al tipo
in questo modo certo cosa ho detto devo
subito farci un video e infatti eccolo
qui siete pronti 321 via ok va bene ci
aggiorniamo esito io ho scelto lui che
lo uso di dice giorno così rimaniamo
aggiornate va bene dai vieni a giocare
torniamo da tu cosa hai avuto il
coraggio di rispondere alla tua f
e allora cosa c'è tutte le volte che hai
detto
topa d'oro la serata è stata tolta culo
scivolava ti abbiamo subito inviati
nella nota ma non sento niente turi non
si sposta chi vota se non sei tu
va bene carissima alta minuti è certa
meraviglia ora è moroso cometa melo
divario gava e le cose i dati della
saras e quante anche cani i soldi per
spaccio
[Musica]
mai piaciuto il video di mezzo cristiana
racing mi raccomando
iscrivetevi al canale e come da degli
stock e servite neanche tutti gli altri
social
fiscali e faccia a me intyre
[Musica]